here is everything you need to know
about the two new mechanics some
interactions to consider and the handful
of returning mechanics that you can find
in ather drift so let's do what you do
on the starting line and talk about the
First new mechanic start your engines
start your engines is a new keyword
ability that can be found on permanence
across the set when a permanent with
start your engines enters under your
control your speed becomes one
this is something that doesn't use a
stack and cannot be responded to by
either player start your engines and
speed is similar to ascend and the
city's blessing start your engines is
the mechanic like Ascend and speed is
the designation like the city's blessing
in short a designation is something that
acts like a marker that other rules and
effects can identify and just like a
send and the city's blessing you cannot
lose this designation even if your
opponent removes all of your permanence
with start your engines once you have
one or more speed you get the ability to
increase your speed by triggering a
certain condition in this case whenever
an opponent loses life during your turn
you can increase your speed by one this
ability can only trigger once each turn
and once you hit four speed you're
considered to have reached max speed and
can't gain anymore it's worth pointing
out that this ability acts just like
every other triggered ability it uses a
stack so it can be copied with cards
like stronic resonator or virtue of
knowledge and you can also counter this
ability with things like stifle and
consigned to memory and if this mechanic
makes its way into modern be mindful of
whose turn you're cracking those
fetchlands on once you hit Max Speed
certain abilities effectively become
unlocked on certain cards for example
the Raceway lands prior to hitting Max
Speed they simply tap for colorless Mana
but once you do you're able to use their
Max Speed abilities there's also cards
like hazarat godseeker and samut the
driving force they don't specifically
have Max Speed abilities but they do
check to see what your speed is remember
speed is simply a marker that other
effects can identify in this case if you
don't have Max Speed hazarat cannot
attack or block next up there's exhaust
perhaps the simplest mechanic we'll see
in the whole of
2025 exhaust abilities are activated
abilities that can only be activated
once during the entire game and that's
literally all there is to it one thing
to keep in mind if you use a card like
Cloudshift or effect ferate on a card
that used their exhaust ability thanks
to rule
4.7 when an object moves from one zone
to another in this case into Exile and
back to the battlefield it becomes a new
game object with no memory of its
previous existence meaning if you
flicker an exhausted creature you can
reactivate their exhaust ability again
moving on to the returning mechanics it
wouldn't be a racing set without some
tricked out rides so of course crew and
vehicles make an
appearance vehicles are generally
non-creature artifacts with the crew
ability at any time you can activate the
crew ability by tapping any number of
creatures whose total power is equal to
or greater than the number next to the
crew ability once you do this the
vehicle becomes an artifact creature
that can attack or block just remember
that once the vehicle becomes a creature
they're subjected to the same rules as
creatures so if you played a vehicle and
then crewed it you wouldn't be able to
attack with that vehicle straight away
thanks to Summoning Sickness so you'd
need a card like kodin Triumph Caster to
give them haste next there's saddle
which only premiered last year in
Thunder Junction saddle is effectively
crew but for creatures you can find this
this mechanic on mostly mounts but the
big difference here is that you can only
activate the ability at sorcery speed
and because mounts are already creatures
when you saddle them they get a bonus
ability like the one on Glory Heath
links which when it attacks while
saddled you can search your library for
a basic planes and put it into your hand
the final returning mechanic is a
classic cycling very simple but
extremely versatile cycling is an
activated ability and cards with cycling
will have the key word followed by a
cost you can cycle at instant speed by
simply playing that cost and discarding
the card and when you do you draw a
card this is an excellent ability that
allows you to cash in cards when they're
no longer needed during a game for
example if you had a bashery tomorrow's
Champion in play and you draw another
copy of them you can simply cycle it
away for a new
card speaking of battery technically
exert is a returning mechanic but it
only features on this card when a
creature uses an ability with exert
they'll become exerted and they won't
untap during your next untap step but
unlike exhaust if you use a card like
acrobatic leap on an exerted creature
there is nothing stopping you from using
that exert ability again of course same
situation as before they'll skip the
next untap step so what's your favorite
mechanic in this set let me know in the
comments be sure to like this video if
you learn anything and subscribe because
if you don't I'll tell wizards not to
reveal who this person is thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
one